So, ah, we've got an interesting release to share with you today.
Ah, Kenton, could you please first introduce yourself?
I'm Kenton Varda, I'm an engineer here.
Cool.  So, what is it you've released today?
So it's called Procol Buffers.
It's the way we encode
structured data here at Google.
It's, um...
The basic idea is, you write a "proto" file
which contains the definitions of
structured data, and then run it through
the protocol compiler
which generate classes in C++ or Java
or Python which represent those
structures that you've defined.
And, each of these classes have accessors
for all the fields you've defined, and then
has methods for parsing and serializing the data
in a compact and very fast format.
It's the format we use for pretty much
all our data interchange here at Google.
Interesting.  So, when a lot of people think of
structured data, they think of XML,
things like that.
So, why are we not using XML?  How did
we get to use this structure?
Well, XML is nice, but, um..
with the sheer quantity of data that we
use here, it just wouldn't work, you know.
It takes a while to decode and
to encode, and it's kind of large.
We need something extremely efficient.
The other problem is that XML, depending
on what kind of data you are representing,
can be kind of cumbersome to use.
Like if you are trying to represent something
like HTML, which is, you know, text with
markup, then XML is great.
But if you're trying to just represent,
you know, data structures that have
some set of fields, each having a simple type,
then XML, it's kind of cumbersome
because you have to
you know, navigate this DOM tree..
and like, get element with name "whatever"
and then get the inner text of that,
and then parse that and this number
and whatever you want to do.
Right.  So this is all, like, typed information?
Yes.  Protocol Buffers are strongly typed.
Interesting.  So, the other comparison that
people make is it sounds a little bit
IDL-ish and CORBA and things like that come out.
is it similar to that in some ways?
Um.  All of these systems have different
strengths and weaknesses.
Um, Protocol Buffers is just a way to encode data,
it's not an RPC system,
though you could use it for RPC,
and we do use it for RPC.
Um, this release does not actually
include any sort of
RPC implementation
and it can actually be...
it's designed to be used with any RPC
implementation that you want to hook it up to
Do you know historically how
we came to end up with Protocol Buffers?
Well, it's a long story...um..
Protocol Buffers in their first incarnation
appeared in, I believe, late 2000
I wasn't working here at the time, but, um...
Jeff Dean and Sanjay Ghemawat,
the guys who are responsible
for a lot of our big technologies
like MapReduce and BigTable
sort of, came up with this, um...
at first.. I don't completely know the
history because I wasn't there -
but I guess at first
it was just, you could define these proto files
and it would just produce a set of constants
you know, numeric constants that you could
use to manually write parsers and encoders
for various formats
and then over time it evolved
to the point where
the protocol compiler automatically
generates everything for you.
OK, cool.  So you as the kind of end user developer
just have this Java class that you get back
that you can manipulate, so that you're saying
GET to get various data back, and SET
to put data into the system, and at a
lower level it's doing stuff with binary files
Yeah, it's really simple,
you just create your message class
and call SET "whatever"
accessors to set each field, and then
serialize the string, or
serialze to a
output stream, or whatever.
OK, so why do you think, ah, you know,
now this is open source and
people can start playing with this
what kind of use cases do you see
where people would want to use this vs.
some of the other solutions that are out there?
Where does this really fit in well?
Basically, if you need a fast, compact
format that's
easy to define, and extensible
meaning you can add fields, remove fields,
and still be able to interact with
older programs that are using
the old version of the format
then, ah, Protocol Buffers
are a good solution.
As I said before, they are not great
for representing structured text.
because they're not a text format,
and you can't just insert structure
into text.
They are also probably not great if you...
...if your first priority is human readability,
because obviously this is a binary format
although there is a text format
that's useful for debugging,
it's primarily a binary format.
OK, you mentioned manipulating the data,
is there versioning built into this schema,
or how does that work?
Ah, yes.  It's..
you don't just declare a version, um..
If you add new fields to your structures
and then encode a message using those new fields
old programs that don't know about them
will just ignore them.
OK.
If you remove a field,
old programs will just
assume it has its default value.
OK, cool.
OK, so that's actually really useful.
not have to mess around with schemas
and working through all of those
kind of systems
if it's built into the protocol itself.
That seems pretty useful.
Cool.
So, any final thoughts for developers
taking a first peek at this
open source package?
Yeah, well, take a look at the docs
download the code, it's all
freely available
and let us know what you think
at our discussion group.
Great, well, thanks so much for
making this happen,
I know a bunch of people that maybe have
left Google that wish they had
Protocol Buffers.
So it's cool to see it out in the wild now,
I really appreciate it.